retired US army colonel William Keegan
he served as the head of the Australian
submarine testing program he's also a
defense advisor and strategist and joins
us now from Washington DC uh Colonel
it's good to have you on the program the
houthis have shown time and time again
that they have the knowledge and KN how
to disrupt the Waterway so what's the
strategy then of any coalition to
counter
them well I think it's important if
you're going to develop a strategy you
have to look at the big picture of
what's really going on this is not a
just a small activity uh by the houthis
by themselves uh for themselves because
there's nothing really strategically to
gain if it's just them what's going on
in the larger view is this is Iran
flexing its muscle in multiple locations
around the region uh whether there's
attacks in Iraq whether there are
attacks in Lebanon or Gaza or in in this
case in the Red Sea by the hooes uh they
are EX exercising uh their muscle to
demonstrate it is a demonstration of
their power in the region and their
potential ability to restrict trade and
restrict movement uh through the Suz
Canal is strategic it's not just a small
activity no but the focus definitely is
at the moment on on that Waterway and on
that area and sort of sea power alone is
not going to be the answer is it from
the Coalition and you can't deal with if
you're going to you know mention Iran
you can't deal with Iran on on a on a
multi-regional uh platform when there
when it's in so many areas or has
influenc in so many areas if you're
going to deal with the houis surely you
also have to deal with them from their
command and control centers on land is
that something that any Coalition at the
moment would consider or would they be
looking for un a un mandate on
that well I think that there's uh the
reason that the Coalition uh which is
inherently a defensive operation um is
having difficulty coalescing at the
moment is because they don't have a
strategic Direction on on what you just
mentioned specifically so you're right
in that in that case uh and in reality
uh the way they stop it is to basically
direct the attacks against the houthis
that are doing that and also Target the
irgc that supporting them uh I you have
to cut off the The Source uh and exert
pressure wherever possible
and in addition to that make it so it's
not worth it's not worth it for the
hooes uh to be a proxy for Iran uh and
that that can be pressure that's brought
on the houthis directly whether it's
command and control and those those
assets that are attacking civilian
shipping or it can be also pressure put
directly on uh Iran which includes
revisiting the sanctions and of course
we saw during the conflict between Yemen
and and Saudi that the houis are a
resilient uh force and a resilient group
but in terms of uh sort of the last 24
hours you know when you have a
commercial vessel that is told to take
strategic or evasive maneuvers against
uh whatever force is being used by the
houthis how does a a merchant vessel do
that when it doesn't have any armed
Personnel on the vessel itself and one
assumes can only maneuver physically you
might say left or
right well that's just that's just the
point they're defenseless so uh you know
they require an escort to defend them
and if you don't get something uh in
place what you'll have is a lot of
traffic uh building up and building up
and if you've ever been in the uh Suez
Canal and I've been there you it traffic
can get stacked up very very very uh
greatly there you know hundreds and
hundreds of vessels uh can be put in a a
waiting status and it could very much be
a disruption to global trade especially
those countries that depend on uh goods
and also uh the Arab countries that need
to ship out oil uh so if it gets uh
plugged up so to speak that will disrupt
even countries that are not targeted by
the houti so it's really unacceptable by
any world standards or legal standards
uh so the the question is how fast will
it take the west and other countries to
coales and do something about it I know
the Saudis have had a a bit of a you
know a pause in their conflict with the
hooes and uh they're reluctant to get
that uh IND danger that agreement uh but
at the same time the Us and other
countries have to act in their interests
they have to take the advice of the
Saudis also obviously but they cannot uh
you cannot just ignore this and let uh
let hooes just Target
uh commercial shipping from from other
countries it's just it's just
intolerable and I don't think it will
stand and I think within the next couple
weeks you'll see some more decisive
steps to put a stop to it we shall see
what does happen for the moment retired
Colonel William Keegan thanks so much
for joining us sir